right so so in a lot of the content
marketing I think the key is
establishing that truck so you can build
community so the community goes from
whatever they were at before it so oh no
here's the guy I can actually trust and
that involves a certain type of
sincerity as opposed to here are the top
10 things you know need to know about
wine you kind of have to start off with
here's what I didn't know about wine now
here's what I'm learning so how do you
how do you kind of like break into
sincerity because they think that is the
real challenge for a lot of content
marketers there's big marketing I think
that's right that's right and I think
you've got a pegged I think the North
Star has to be truth I mean it's it's
quite simple how do you know it for your
free years like let's say someone starts
out they might not have all the
knowledge but they don't know how do
they know they're being sincere like
where's the line what are they oh I
think that I think it's a technique for
sincere I know but I don't I don't think
you know look if you do not know what
the truth or not the truth is within
your own body of your own self well then
there's nothing I can do or you can do
to help anybody I would say 99% of the
people know the truth when you come out
the gate and you're 23 years old and you
want to be a life coach you know that
you haven't lived life yet it's not
super complicated like like when you
want to teach people how to make money
on 23 because somebody who's 53 told you
this is the quick way to make money but
you know that you've never made money
like you know that to be true